alors que signifie favoriser l'approche
globale l'approche globale impose de ne
pas limiter l'action des services à la
seule interception des flux et je pense
que quand on on parle de lutte contre
les trafics de stupéfiants on ne peut
pas effectivement se contenter de saisir
du produit on le sait ce n'est pas
l'effet attendu ça permet de sortir du
marché un certain nombre
de une des quantités non non
négligeablees de produits mais ce n'est
pas suffisant pour démanteler en en
profondeur les organisations les
organisations criminelles donc pour les
démentanteler ces organisations
criminelles
euh on doit définir une stratégie autour
des cibles d'intérêt prioritaires on on
a défini une une stratégie autour des
cibles d'intérêts prioritaires les
identifier et les entraver donc où
qu'elles soi en France comme à
l'étranger nous avons eu plusieurs
plusieurs réussites
significatives depuis depuis la mise en
place de l'offaste avec 22 22 Cies
d'intérêts prioritaires qui ont été qui
ont été interceptés euh notre rôle est
aussi d' analyser les violences
criminelles l'approche l'approche
globale c'est ça c'est d'analyser
violences criminelles en lien avec les
trafics de stupéfiants les enlèvements
les séquestrations les homicides et les
tentatives d'omicide et leur lien avec
les trafics et puis enfin bien sûr
l'approche globale c'est lutter contre
les flux financiers liés au trafic de
stupéfiants le blanchiment alors la
corruption on n'est pas forcément sur du
flux financier à proprement à proprement
parler même si ils en génèrent
inévitablement et puis bien sûr le
dernier volet c'est celui de la saisie
des avoirs criminels l'approche globale
nécessite enfin et aussi de prendre en
compte la dimension internationale des
trafics au plan opérationnel mais
également au plan stratégique avec la
définition de priorités stratégiqu je
vous le disais en introduction cette
coopération elle est à la fois
bilatérale et multilatérale
multilatérale j'ai à l'esprit bien
évidemment les liens que nous avons avec
Europol qui sont extrêmement
forts à la fois en participant au cycle
politique d'Europol et puis à toutes les
task forces opérationnelles piloté par
par par l'agence européenne et qui
concerne qui concerne bien sûr la France